voilà la cour d'honneur du château de
culan qui est fermé depuis 18 mois cette
forteresse médiévale du 12e siècle
surplombant la renom est classé monument
historique
c'est l'un des trois châteaux en france
à posséder encore c ur en bois sont
propriétaires edouard marquis est décédé
fin 2020 elle avait légué dans son
testament au département du cher le legs
a été refusée au vu de l'importance des
travaux à réaliser on est à peu près à
2,5 3 millions d'euros d'investissements
dans les trois premières entre 3 et 5
ans et ensuite on a à peu près à 10
millions d'euros de jusqu'à 15 ans la
mère des douars marquis va donc
prochainement mettre l'édifice à la
vente le but c'est que le château sera
ouvert au public on aura jamais de
grosses entreprises sur circulant il
faut pas on est vraiment un un
territoire très rural l'objectif du
château c'est de créer une certaine
dynamique touristique sur le territoire
et d'ailleurs ça va aussi avec
l'objectif de la commune de la
communauté de communes berry grand sud
d'essayer d'avoir un atout touristique
essentielle au développement touristique
et commercial pour les commerçants et
les artisans ces commerçants qui voient
toujours passer les touristes en quête
de visiter ce joyau quand ils viennent
ils me demandent toujours si château il
est ouvert six comment ça se passe pour
le château moi je suis un peu perdue
parce que je peux pas trop leur répondre
c'est compliqué pour permettre quand
même aux gens de rester un petit peu
acculant et devoirs quand même le
château est un petit circuit découverte
qui a été fait pour pouvoir découvrir le
château en fête sous tous ses angles
avant la crise sanitaire le château et
la commune accueillait entre quinze et
vingt mille visiteurs chaque année un
manque à gagner économique et des gens
qui viennent le samedi y en a qui
viennent là en semaine donc bon ici
s'arrête prendre un cros croûte des
trucs comme ça donc
cc c'est un plus pour le pour tout
commerce quoi elle avait le boulanger
enfin la l'épicier tout quoi l'ancien
propriétaire il avait quand même des
pros et des projets
intéressants bah oui pour faire vivre et
faire vivre la commune enfin il avait
plein de projets dans sa tête ce château
qui avait conquis fabien et sa femme qui
se sont installés à culan en 2020 et
n'ont toujours pas pu le visiter
c'est un super beau village quand même
même si on peut voir le château que de
l'eau et donc ça me fait pas regretter
du tout et je c'est vrai que j'espère
quelqu'un de correct et motivés pourra
récupérer le château et le retaper et
voilà correct et motivés et pourquoi pas
un client du ceinture sein qui tente sa
chance